olá pessoal aqui quem fala é dar que
sejam muito bem vindos é mais um vídeo e
pra quem não conhece o lugar que
permitem dois que britney mação e um
deles foi atacado muito ressentimento
por cães selvagens e entretanto teve
cuidado caso de fazer essas coisas mas
eu já estava indo embora porque eu
deixei uma quinta e esta quinta que o be
quer dar a conhecer os mas é que temos
de que ainda vamos ter que andar um
bocado e pelo caminho de mostrar coisas
muito interessantes mesmo que o tesouro
foi lá no meu trailer quando vim aqui
pra casa de máquinas abandonadas lá tem
trator trituradora de tudo tenham lagos
com fatos com tudo lá dentro então pelo
km do solo diz mostrando essas coisas
todas talvez faça vir sobretudo se vocês
comentarem aí estou aqui com um olá tudo
bem é isso deixei online se inscrevam e
embora para aventura do vizinho porque
temos medo porque eu sou jogo agora
mesmo é de curingas o coringa português
forma então só tenho que comandam agora
é só para a aventura explorar e já sabem
que sofrem nós aqui no canal inscrevam
deixei muito longe ai que quero fazer
ano eu sou andrezinho não sendo tomadas
repertã qual é a tua idéia talvez um
sinal que às vezes estas transmissões
ligadas directamente fazem uma conjunção
e não além disso não faz nada mas não
sou está com um bocadinho [ __ ] l em
cima vamos ter que subir o estudo vida
naquelas bandas que cantam bichos
inscrever na fundação unitins caravana
vem se falando mal de mim não muda nada
só deu lhe uma esquerda anos
nós temos que seguir até lá tanto agora
não lembra a cia por aqui
o é bom é bom sabermos que não estamos
só tocou muitas dúvidas porque eu apenas
deixei que o blog o [ __ ] eu acho que
sua visita a este lugar umas duas vezes
portanto temos que tentar o que chegando
único louco
dentre os temas na quinta assombrada eu
quero por em assombrar o caminho certo a
seguir muitos anos muito mais acaba
mas tudo por uma boa causa pessoal nós
vamos reencontrar o bode e obama e
espero que eu seja um bem mas o bode de
ficar tom sus mas tão só o esportivo é
completamente branco europeu todo branco
e aqui é só lá mais ó terra
surgiram então deve estar tudo que está
aí agora eu não faço ideia mas vamos ver
estou cansado e mirante como namorada de
marco antônio um trator e banda mas sabe
que tem a direita do ataque não
abandonar ainda não sabe se a assombrar
a uma casa que aquela tampa e deve dar
para abrir já teve uma plataforma em
parceira com é isso aqui é a prova de
que os mandantes cuja missão é ver o
bigode e oab
isso tem que ser outro vídeo software em
que o dente entramos ali
comentei aqui dentro agora eu não sei se
é por aqui
o frei e eu aceitei se inscrevam nos lá
em cima
jd que aquelas caravanas parecem boas
campanhas no ranking de ram
nós até podemos fazer algumas recriações
do working da equipe não dá pra fazer
olha o que tem muito espaço aqui em
baixo tudo e dá pra fazer aqui um ataque
de zumbis e tudo - mais do que o do rock
desde que lembra uma audiência dos
filmes de mídia nem a pauta e vamos pra
lá
tem muita coisa de rico quando é que o
corajoso e custeio sul tem que morrer
guarda redes das balizas do eu não sei
onde é que os gaúchos a bola e bateu mas
tenho uma idéia agora se eu colocar uma
cultura de se cortar só vou conseguir
alguma coisa vamos voltar pra fazer
alguma coisa alguma coisa contou
alguma coisa não tem banheiro com obras
ou frases tipo tipo veículo uma banheira
44 sua montanha um gol as rodas do
trator o negócio já está andando aqui
fazendo lembrar que o clube da zona de
guerra
não dá pra fazer lutas de software já é
muito bom
meu deus meu aqui surgem muitas idéias
sério só se beneficiar de algumas destas
idéias que ouvir como tem muito porque
nós vamos fazer aqui mas só se vocês
comentarem o item que mais coisas
estragadas tempo um celular e um
telefone antigo
a placa de som
em contraste à ii com coco estão
colocando a faca é muito grande eu não
sei como é que eu não pisar isso então
pensei nunca percebi meu deus
ok vamos ter que ir embora ok pessoal
estamos muito quase nós aqui já
conseguimos ganhar mais colorida
nossa que já conseguimos vir luiz que
levando meu deus eu estou lá em cima
embora ainda não conheça a nossa eu
estava muito não vou tentar chamar a
mari no microfone e falar e cantar a lei
não faz se na escola foi postaram as
incertezas e cantares intensas e
deixei-o última vez
uma casca de madeira como é que o céu e
silva contra uma equipe até aqui que
tenho que encarar que esta fita é
primeira vez que vou entrar aqui sem
história que o dono então vamos tentar
não fazer gosta
agora é só dele aqui enfrenta tanta que
mostrar que uma coisa com que as coisas
o dono de cinco em alguns lotes ou então
aqui tô aqui não não isso é muito fundo
é que nem desde então falar serviço é
muito fundo
isso é que deve ter um metro de altura
ai ai vou falar sobre isso é muito fundo
mesmo a luz no fundo não esteja aqui e
esses outros famosos poço pessoas caírem
morrem
o que eu sempre ouvi falar que nem assim
em tese o caneco a esses postos gigante
parece que são pequenos mas que é capaz
de meter um metro é verdade que é este
aqui eu acho que não porque eu consegui
ver o fundo aqui olha tudo aproximamos
ben ali no centro que ela já não é
mister acho que essa luta assim ea e não
quer arriscar perder amigos
a cápsula possa fazer o texto num
próximo vídeo portanto já sabem tudo
aquilo que vocês virem aqui que achar
interessante comenta imaginou passar
umas botas de um fato de mergulho de
entrar aqui dando número 27 idiomas têm
mais longe daquilo eu acho que isso é
muito fundo para voltar à caraças eu
queira que estou muito chato
vamos passar agora estou aqui só vez um
só comer com uma vaca vasco colocou e
sim esta zona a taxa era chegar a isto
tudo com muito medo das vacas porque eu
acho que elas estão à solta e células
tipo se sentirem ameaçadas de qualquer
maneira elas vão contra nós vamos morrer
são vacas elas dão em marrawah com elas
quando viram que eu nunca vim aqui mesmo
em cima tá na hora de ele morrer sua
próxima encontro emocionante está
prestes a acontecer subir uma quebra
é aí que os uniu seu estado goiano hobby
eu juntar uma cobrança ou não essa fusão
eu banbury bigode road
olhe eu gostava de velho tem 12 gols na
cara do tamanho de uma cabra tem cara
toda preta bola lhe como é que eu fico
tão grande só não fico muito grande
entre o que está a acontecer é outra
quebra para fazer xixi no sábado 15 pode
estar podre está em gente o meu china
outra câmera pessoal sério de estímulo
aqui neste vídeo o culto à risca a
menina
vamos lá visitar o estado da vaca e
aquelas pisar em cocô de faca e
documento e como é que eu vou passar um
estudo com o correio já conceito
fizestes dantas álvaro mora por bobô fez
uma curta do vaccine trás de mim por aí
só tem uma duas três quatro cinco ou vai
me ver o time além quer saber de uma
hora
olhe eu olhar pole e ana maria está com
o olho preto
olhe
é o [ __ ] olário bang bang fugiu bode
sul tudo god andou indo andré pode me
lembro de ir embora e isso eu estou bem
triste agora deixe tom aqui a comida que
a gente chegou e não pararam continuam a
comer então o número infinito não para o
primeiro naquela linha ou aquela muito
emocionante
ela acaba liberato ok eu não sei o que
fazer eu não sair vamos nos conhecer
já não temos poder o nome sequer robô de
responder sempre o nome é a gente ainda
estava aqui do nosso lado ainda nos
treinos também tem essas caravanas e eu
não sei o que tem ali dentro não faz
idéia dentro tem que cuidar a portaria
ainda alguma coisa a sério dentro não
quero arriscar um motor de gota relva já
o corta-luz de fernando que a engenheira
que é o do tipo de uma máquina aqui que
lavar a alma está sem nenhuma a não tem
cinto e eu tenho o meu tambor mas
explodir uma campanha destas aí fica a
ideia pessoal grande idéia
vamos lá então o ponto eu só quero uma
festa em abril [ __ ]
eu vou tentar entrar ali dentro e ver
onde a questão eu acho que subiram em
piscinas ou ambiental e autover mas o
bode entrou no empreendimento estiver
uma vaca aqui dentro ainda não tá eu
consegui está então a tudo eu não sei se
o dono deixou passar para o estado mas
eu também não vou fazer nada mau tempo
afectou acho que também só para vocês
terem uma noção de como é aqui dentro
tem muito feno e onde está enfiado ina
que o buraco não sei onde obviamente já
nos conhece sabe que eu contei o que eu
disse ban ki moon por uma investigação
está muito atenta tentar conhecer ainda
wang lindo englobando me não é possível
é possível ter um filtro que vinha tão
linda que eu vou estar aqui a bordo
incluindo sou eu
ainda vai me criticar
o que o dante meu isso os fãs assistindo
estava causando que não vai lá através
de meu deus tenha um bem de cabras
olha isso dante está muito assustador
agora tem uma carona pra mim tipo dona
do ganho não é justo ir embora
bor e amauri
eu sou amiga sério sério mas companhia
já nem está andou circulando com bons
boye ano além do seu dono do blog ana
ana agore bori amary não diz nada nem
quer saber se eu tenho comigo eu tenho
amigos não tem tudo aqui eu não precisa
temer e sérgio tomas sentir agora tipo
que os mais rejeitados samba de itu bem
triste agora vai ficar a saber que
barack obama sente mesmo que os pais
rejeitados sei lá o meu filho foi de
féris já nem conhece o pai é muito
triste e não [ __ ] quando estava quase a
tocar trompete estava quase quase do
câmbio
o pessoal acha que a única opção agora é
ir para casa descansar pelo menos um
blog já viu [ __ ] também já viu jamais
conheceram mas o que eu acho que deve
estar a acontecer é que eles acham que
eu os quero levar de volta e eu aqui
estou melhor porque eu tenho amigos têm
comida que podem comer à vontade podem
beber à vontade tem a companhia de deus
tem umas dez carros 20 cavalos e latão
muito escolhidas aqui dentro também
então com certeza que eles não querem
que os leva de volta é triste mas eu sou
mais feliz aqui na área e amor andam mas
vale a vale está o sentimento ainda eu
sei porque ela tinha só come tem formas
de conseguir conquistar o blog o [ __ ]
deixei muitos comentários mesmo deixei
muito claro que minha estrela e comentem
tudo aquilo que vocês querem que eu faço
aqui de tentar andar com trator de
tentar explodir uma caravana fazer uma
banheira com rodas tudo aquilo que vocês
possam imaginar desde já foram retiradas
como tem mesmo muito que eu posso fazer
deixa muito lex foi nós aqui no canal
inscrevam-se fiquem bem e até aproximar